comment vous allez aujourd'hui bien pour
écouter je serais content de vous
retrouver je sais que c'est une période
où je poste assez peu de chance j'ai
malheureusement pas trop de temps savez
je suis sur la route avec amazon on
voyait toute la semaine je suis en
vadrouille mais aujourd'hui j'ai pris un
petit moment pour vous parler d'un
nouveau smartphone série le mic m'a
demandé de vous parler son nouveau
smartphone c'est laurie 2007 et bien
évidemment je trouve ça intéressant
parce que leur île 1701 smartphone qui
se positionne entre l'entrée et le
milieu de gamme un tarif très agressif
très intéressant et avec des specs qui
sont cohérentes par rapport en tout cas
ce qu'on va attendre à ce type aux
logiques produits situés à ce prix là le
produit il est situé là dedans enfin il
situe là dedans normalement puisque moi
oui je l'est déjà c'est celui là on va
donc se parler de se réunit 7 mai juste
avant et si ce n'est pas déjà fait vous
invite à venir vous abonner pourquoi
parce que bien évidemment je vous parle
de teck je vous parle de nouveautés
smartphone je vous parle d'ordinateurs
demande connecte et l'egypte assurent
tous deux vous et votre vie numérique
pour vous abonner c'est très facile vous
cliquez sur le petit bouton rouge que
vous avez juste là si les rouges
si vous n'êtes toujours pas abonné vous
actionnez la cloche comme ça vous serez
notifié dès qu'une nouvelle vidéo
arrivera
côté packaging quelque chose qui est
très connu à maintenant chers ennemis
ceux jaunes qui est plutôt sympa on
trouve le branding de tous les côtés
jamas que jamais un canton louvre c'est
le message veille où elles comme tout il
me family merci beaucoup
on va voir à l'intérieur regarder de
quoi protéger notre smartphone une
petite coque transparente
donc ça c'est bien est toujours très
très très pratique un petit guide de
démarrage très rapide quelques
informations pourquoi pas ça c'est cool
merci ennemis mais surtout on va
retrouver un bloc de charge rapide je
vous le dévoile dans quelques instants
vous allez voir ça c'est vraiment un des
atouts de ce smartphone sans oublier
d'un côté votre câble pour le recharger
en usb et de l'autre côté oui mesdames
et messieurs sexe suis pas bien que ce
exceptionnel en tout cas c'est très très
bien nous sommes en usb c'est et ça
c'est cool
alors moi ce que j'aime bien déjà c'est
le dos si vous voyez bien on a cette
espèce de double effet et fait un peu
différent sur cette partie vraiment sur
la bande audio ou noter le branding et
demi que je trouve très jolie et l'autre
partie du bas ça c'est assez sympa alors
bien évidemment ce qui serait
intéressant de ce smartphone quand vous
lisez ça doit être une coque
transparente pas vraiment laissé
apparent on a un gros module photo ici
avec quatre capteurs je vous le
détaillant quelques instants on va
retrouver six sur la tranche un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui font office
de bouton et qui déverrouille
extrêmement rapidement en dessous un
haut parleur mono louis haut parleur
mono ici de quoi leurs charges et si on
use bcsa je voulais dire on retrouve
également ici son micro une prise jack
donc ça c'est aussi très très cool les
boutons ici de volume sur le côté votre
tiroir de cartes sim je vous détacher
dans quelques instants et sur le dessus
et bien absolument rien smartphones qui
est plutôt bien une très bonne tenue
demain on est comme ça des smartphones
qui sont assez grand parce que oui si on
à l'écran quand même de 6,5 pouces
résolution full hd + 2400 par 1080
pixels
c'est un ratio vingt neuvième et surtout
ce smartphone ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on a un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 90 hertz alors là je
me suis mis à l'extérieur vous voyez les
reflets centre profite encore un peu du
ciel bleu volige est directement à
l'automne 90' ce que ça va faire ce que
ça vous apporter de la fluidité pour
venir naviguer sur internet pour tous
vos contenus et notamment pour le gaming
parce que oui c'est un smartphone ou
remy a quand même mis l'accent sur
gaming donc si vous voulez jouer à des
jeux qui acceptent de 90 ans
eh bien on peut le faire là dessus et ça
c'est vraiment très très bien la
luminosité est correcte sans être
complètement folle on a une luminosité
de 480 nietzsche ok ça marchera et on a
également un taux d'échantillonnage
c'est pour le tactile de 120 hertz donc
pour le gaming bon ça fonctionne et une
fois de plus sur un smartphone d'entrée
milieu de gamme
ça fera parfaitement la faire côté audio
on va retrouver un haut parleur mono
regarder jouer le met à fond et si tu
ici sur la tranche
alors si vous poussez le son à fond il
en a marre tendance un petit peu a
saturé ce qui n'est pas anormal là
dessus donc vous mais c'est un peu
profiter la meilleure expérience audio
avec les haut parleurs et si vous voulez
vraiment venir maximiser l'expérience et
bien vous branchez ici un petit casque
en jack et là vous allez beaucoup mieux
alors vous pouvez également l'utiliser
en bluetooth parce que oui vous avez du
bluetooth 5.0 pour venir connecter un
casque très facilement donc vous avez le
choix côté performances on retrouve un
processeur de médiathèque c'est un elio
g 95 processeur vraiment situé dans
l'entrée milieu de gamme qui vous
apportera suffisamment de puissance pour
jouer à de nombreux jeux du playstation
attention vous allez pas avoir ici les
meilleures performances pour le gaming
mais je dirais que pour beaucoup de jeux
sur le plateau des jeux pas trop
gourmands et bien vous invite quoi faire
vous avez trois configurations
différentes têtes giga de ram 6 giga de
ram ou 8 gigas de ram c'est de la lpddr2
4x pour les plus technophiles d'entre
vous et si vous n'êtes pas technophiles
sachez que plus chiffre va monter et
plus vous allez gagner en fluidité et
donc on confort et ça sera mieux pour le
gaming et pour naviguer d'une façon
générale sans le smartphone côté
stockage une techno qui est connu au
niveau de la ram c'est de lui fs 2.1 ce
n'est pas les dernières techno de
ramener sa part est aussi normal
une fois de plus sur un smartphone
d'entrée milieu de gamme vous avez choix
entre deux configurations soit 64 giga
de stockage soit 128 que vous pouvez
venir augmenter
c'est une carte micro sd partie
logicielle on tourne ici sur remy wahi
basé sur un android dit je sais pas si
vous connaissez le mirail simple
d'utilisation assez intuitive safronov
vous avez tous vos paramètres ici et
icônes sont assez sympa on comprend très
facilement et on sort pas très très
facilement partie affichage luminosité
vous avez un mode sont vous pouvez venir
active et le confort des yeux pouvaient
venir les votes sécurité à fabriquer les
grands classiques on va retrouver sur un
smartphone sur android mais je dirais qu
un des points forts de ce smartphone est
souvent c'est un peu l'idée des
smartphones qu'on retrouve dans l'entrée
et milieu de gamme et bien c'est la
grosse autonomie et une fois de plus
réunis a vraiment mis l'accent dessus
avec une très grosse batterie de 5000
milliampères heures ce qui me permettra
de l'utiliser pendant une journée et
demi à deux jours
une fois de plus en fonction de vous et
de vos usages mais je dirais qu un poids
qui est très intéressant c'est que vous
avez un chargeur de 30 watts inclus dans
la boîte ce qui fait que lorsque vous
avez assez peu de temps devant vous et
qui vous manque un peu d'autonomie et
bien vous le branchez vous attendez à
les dix minutes un quart d'heure et vous
êtes parti pour un long moment et ça
s'est vraiment bien puisque vous le
recharger 2 01 50 % en seulement 26
minutes
côté photo alors là c'est là ça devient
intéressant vous avez à l'arrière pas
moins de quatre capteurs alors quatre
capteurs ça me fait toujours une très
très belle promesse moi je vais surtout
retenir deux essentiels on va voir le
capteur principal c'est un 48 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 1.8 c'est un capteur
samsung alors les capteurs samsung sont
un peu moins bien que les capteurs sony
mais bon une fois de plus s'est vu le
positionnement du smartphone ça fera le
taf
vous savez c'est un ultra grand-angle
capteur de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f
2.3 avec un champ de vision 219 degrés
vous avez ensuite un capteur de 2
mégapixels qui est là pour le mode
portrait 2 méga pixels noirs et blancs
ici youtube bref 2.4 et enfin vous avez
un capteur pour la macro 2 mégapixels
qui rêvent de points 4 avec une distance
pour venir shooter 2 4 cm vous pouvez
faire de la vidéo chat en 4k à 30 images
par seconde et surtout un des focus qui
est intéressant ici c'est que vous avez
de la vidéo stabiliser stabilité d'un
point de vue logiciel parce que oui si
vous n'avez absolument aucune
stabilisation optique et à l'avant vous
avez un petit capteur qui est planqué
issia capteur de 16 mégapixels et qui
ouvre à f 2.0
vous le voyez ici on a quelque chose qui
est plutôt bien c'est pas extrêmement
saturé mais c'est vraiment la différence
qu'on va retrouver notamment au niveau
des capteurs 48 mégapixels entre le
samsung et le sony
le samsung fera halte à fumer sera un
peu en dessous de ce qu'on va retrouver
au niveau des capteurs de sony un peu
moins de saturation un peu
piqué c'est un pur est plus terne voyait
au niveau des branches ici mais
néanmoins ça fait quand même le taf et
ça reste très correct vous amène à
bordeaux dans une très très jolie balade
on est ici à pey-berland vous pouvez
venir vous mais en x 2 ça ira x 5 ça
commence un peu à piquer parce que ça
lisse et il faut dix voiliers bon voilà
je crois que c'est à proscrire
l'ultra grand angle est pas mal on avait
une différence du colorimétrie entre
grand-angle et du très grand temps les
la voyez on rajoute un peu de bruit dans
le ciel c'est pas ce qu'on va retrouver
le mieux pour moi le meilleur capteur à
utiliser sur ce smartphone pourrait m'en
faire de très beaux souvenirs
c'est le capteur principal celui qu'on
trouve ici c'est le 48 mégapixels et
voyait plus trop quand on a quand même
une différence une différence aussi au
niveau de l'expo vous voyez ici au
niveau voiliers de pey-berland vous le
voyez notamment ici capteur principal ça
fonctionne sur l'ultra grand temps tout
de suite c'est un peu plus craint mais
on a une problématique au niveau de la
gestion d'autres lumières et c'est un
peu moins bon mais une fois de plus sur
un smartphone dans cette gamme de tarifs
là et je vous le détaillant quelques
instants ça ne paraît pas anormale et
lorsque vous venez zoomer voyez bon bout
d'un moment où vient lycée et c'est
toujours un peu la même chose on est sur
du très grand temps aussi à toute la
problématique de gestion de la des
hautes lumières vous le voyez sur le
côté si c'est un glacier que je vous
recommande
si vous venez à bordeaux dumas très
sympa très très bon capteur principal ça
fera le tas février dès qu'on se
rapproche un petit peu ça va mais vous
rapprocher beaucoup plus eh bien on perd
un peu en qualité sur les quais de
bordeaux ça fonctionne l'ultra grand
temps le voit la différence de
colorimétrie la ciel est bleu le ciel
est bleu un petit pot aux roses et c'est
une petite différence mais une fois de
plus ce n'est pas anormal dans cette
gamme de tarifs ici on vient où met on
commence un peu alice et on le voit
notamment sur les personnages ici et si
vous ou métro et bien voilà ça pique un
peu points importants à connaître et non
des moindres vous avez ici juin nfc mais
surtout vous avez la possibilité d'avoir
une double carte sim plus une carte
micro sd vous avez donc trois slots
disponibles à l'intérieur alors double
carte sim on pourrait se dire quel est
l'usagé
quel est l'intérêt et bien si vous avez
une carte pro et une carte perso c'est
bien si vous avez deux carte perso vous
pouvez le faire également
et si vous êtes frontaliers vous avez
une carte d'un pays une carte de l'autre
dans tous les cas c'est très pratique et
le fait en plus d'avoir cet emplacement
pour la carte micro sd vous permet comme
je vous le disais de venir ajouter de la
capacité de stockage à votre smartphone
et ça parfois c'est dans l'église à bhl
mais je dirais qu'un autre point qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en plus vous n'avez
pas seulement deux ans de garantie ce
qui est déjà très très bien avec la
série 7 2 me vous avez jusqu'à 3 ans
garantis et ça
c'est vraiment bien et très rassurant
mais qu'en est-il niveau tarif parce que
oui forcément c'est toujours une bonne
la guerre garder je vous ai tous noté là
dessus vous avez trois config
différentes vous n'êtes pas appris par
coeur une occasion là tu ne vous
inquiétez pas la première qu'on fixe et
4 gigas de ram + 64 giga de stockage
vous êtes à 179 euros
vous avez également une version première
monte un peu en fluidité avec 6 jega
drame + 64 giga de stockage vous êtes à
199 euros et si vous voulez ce qui se
fait de mieux en terme de fluidité et en
capacité de stockage
vous montez sur une version 8 gigas de
ram et 128 go de stockage à 249 euros
dont là la différence vraiment faire par
rapport à vous vos besoins si vous
pensez que vous voulez de la fluidité
est bien la version avec 6 giga de ram
peut être intéressante on est quand même
un delta de 20 euros alors 20 euros on
peut dire que c'est pas grand chose mais
20 euros c'est quand même de l'argent il
faut donc venir réfléchir en disant est
ce que je veux un peu de fluidité pas
trop de fuites et khadiga drame ça fera
le taf mais si on veut quelque chose qui
est un peu plus fluide et un peu plus
smooth et bien je pense que monter
jusqu'à 6 giga de ram c'est peut être
quand même relativement pas mal dites
vous bien que de toute façon vous avez
toujours derrière votre stockage
supplémentaire grâce à votre carte
microsd mais si vous pouvez vous le
permettre
et si vous voulez la meilleure config
avec ce smartphone le 8 gigas de ram
plus en est usuel de stockage fera
vraiment la faire a vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en
barrant commentaires qu est ce que vous
pensez de ce nouveau smartphone de rémy
est ce qu'il pourrait vous tenter est ce
que vous trouvez intéressant qu'est ce
que vous pensez de rythmique est une
marque qui est encore assez jeune
en france qui est arrivé ya pas très
longtemps mais qui a une gamme qui
s'étoffe qui est extrêmement
intéressante
mark et moi tout ça bien évidemment en
commentaire et quand on se retrouve très
rapidement jusqu'à fin octobre début
novembre
j'ai publié quelques vidéos parce que je
suis encore sur la route avec amazon
mais à partir de novembre ça va repartir
au taquet avec plein de vidéos donc là
ça va être extrêmement coule sur ce je
vous embrasse pour les soins de vous
c'était monsieur gros et à très bientôt
[Musique]
son mini mixte dimanche
est ce la caf et no 10 a baissé